[Music]
this is what a virtual interview looks
like
this is what it feels like interviews
are already nerve-wracking but when you
throw a video element into it it becomes
that much more anxiety-inducing for a
lot of people
that's ashley anderson she's a certified
career coach and remote working pro
she's been doing it for 10 years i
specialize
in helping job seekers transition from
traditional office jobs into telecommute
roles
with many of us home now chances are
your next interview will be done through
a screen
and well it's really hard to make that
connection
with the interviewer but one of the best
ways you can do that is to present
really well and she's here virtually to
teach you how to do just that
not this
[Music]
step one set the scene
so ideally you want to have a nice clean
simple background just the blank wall is
perfectly fine
you also want to think about lighting
for example if you have lighting behind
you
you could end up looking like a
silhouette on the screen
ideally natural lighting is the best so
if you have a window that you can
face or a window to your side that would
be perfect
but also if you don't have a window to
provide natural lighting
you can resort to using a desk lamp and
you really want to have your camera
at eye level with you that way you're
not looking up
at the interviewer and they're peering
up your nostrils and you're also not
looking down on them
if you just grab a couple of books and
pile them up and sit the laptop on top
of that that is going to raise it enough
to bring that camera right at the eye
level for you
step two plan your outfit
do a little bit of research about the
company so you know what their culture
is going
into it you don't want to show up to
your virtual interview
in a really nice suit if they're a very
casual company
keep your your ensemble really basic
don't go for
really busy patterns and try to stay
away from solid colors that are really
bright as those
can kind of wash you out on screen so
you might not necessarily consider your
headphones as being an accessory or part
of your everyday outfit
but it's something that you definitely
need to consider not using
when you are getting prepared for a
remote interview when you think of
somebody with headphones in
there's somebody that's unapproachable
and somebody that you don't want to
speak to so
forgo using the headphones and just
stick with using the external speakers
microphones
that you have on your computer
step three test your tech
it's making sure that your webcam is
working your speakers
are working and another super super
important thing is your
internet you really need to make sure
you have enough internet speed
generally speaking programs like zoom
prefer 1.8 megabits per second in order
to stream a one-on-one video call
and you can easily test your internet
speed going on google and just typing
speed tests and you'll get tons of
different options
if you're relying on wi-fi that's kind
of a little
inconsistent with the connectivity you
can always just invest in an ethernet
cable
plug that directly into your computer
and into your modem
you're going to have a much more stable
internet connection
step 4 is practice
[Music]
and a great way to do that is just to
you know use a friend or a family member
who's willing to hop on a video call
with you
it really makes all the difference and
especially when it comes to eye contact
you know
our tendency is to look down on the
screen but what that actually looks like
on the other side
is that you're looking away and not
genuinely looking at the person that
you're talking to
so it's always important to practice and
look directly
into the camera if you get easily
distracted by your own
image on the screen a really simple
thing you can do to avoid that is just
use a post-it note and cover up your own
image that way you're not going to be
distracted by it and out of sight and
out of mind
step 5 interview
it's inevitably going to happen that a
distraction may come around
so don't ever panic when something
happens
the more that you do or if you make a
quick decision to turn off your audio or
your video as a knee-jerk reaction
that can actually be more detrimental
than the actual distraction itself
but if it does cause the interviewer to
get interrupted with what they're doing
you definitely want to address it and
not pretend like it didn't happen you
want to make sure that you're able to
say oh
my bad that happened and move forward
after that when you're at home
even when you're on an interview you
kind of have that more casual atmosphere
than actually going into an office
building to interview
and with that casual feeling you might
end up doing something that you wouldn't
even
think of in an office setting for
example having your phone out so just
turn it off and
put it out of sight and make sure you
have all of your internet browsers and
windows closed you don't need that open
really the only thing you should have
open on your computer during the
interview is the program that you're
using to conduct the interview
remote interviews and video interviews
are a lot different
they really are but as they become more
mainstream it's important that we adapt
and adjust to them
that way we can still continue on with
our careers and making career moves and
not letting the fear of video interviews
hold us back